[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
hoy nos acompaña el ministro de defensa
de colombia diego molano el 19 de junio
los colombianos votarán en segunda
vuelta para elegir a su próximo
presidente
gustavo petro o rodolfo fernández y el 7
de agosto concluirá el mandato de iván
duque hoy nos acompaña en esta
entrevista el ministro de defensa porque
la seguridad y la defensa han sido dos
pilares fundamentales de la legislatura
del conservador duque señor ministro
buenas tardes encanta de saludarle que
dónde está marta un saludo muy especial
entonces le quería hacer unas preguntas
para que repasemos cuáles han sido esos
puntos clave de la legislatura en
materia de seguridad me gustaría empezar
con algunas cifras que reportan algunas
organizaciones independientes para que
las contrastemos según diferentes
organizaciones el otro día el instituto
para el desarrollo de la paz
publicaba un informe en el que se dice
que desde el inicio del mandato de iván
duque hasta la fecha del 4 de junio ha
habido más de
930 líderes sociales asesinados
245 ex guerrilleros que acogieron a los
acuerdos asesinados y más de 260
masacres que han dejado mil cuatro más
de 1.400 víctimas esas son las cifras
que manejan las organizaciones además un
aumento de la violencia de los
territorios de parte de los grupos
armados ilegales también los cultivos
ilícitos han estado a la baja pero la
producción de cocaína está en en cifras
máximas en el histórico entonces me
gustaría contrastar con usted estas
cifras y a ver qué balance hace usted de
de estas cifras y de estas cifras
preocupantes también para las
organizaciones internacionales colombia
a lo largo de la historia tenía una
tradición de violencia que se fundamenta
en unos grupos armados organizados
su fuente de financiamiento es el
narcotráfico y kutxa
acción se nutre de sus recursos
narcotráfico para generar violencia
buscar tener influencia política y son
ellos los que a lo largo de la historia
colombia han generado hechos de
violencia y terrorismo cuando inicia el
presidente iván duque su administración
el país había acabado de firmar dos años
antes del acuerdo de la habana pero el
país no quedó en paz eso hizo que el
énfasis de la política de seguridad
ciudadana y de seguridad nacional se
enfocará en cómo desmantelar esas
organizaciones o símbolos del mal que
son en esa época seis disidencias de las
farc que habían traicionado el acuerdo u
otros que nunca entraron lln el clan del
golfo tres grupos pequeños pero
peligrosos en los caparrós los pelusos y
los puntilleros hoy al final su mandato
quedan tres grupos el l n las
disidencias de la fábrica clan del golf
y se han reducido de 13 mil 800 hombres
a casi 11 mil 150 mil 100 de ellos
1.200 de ellos en venezuela se fueron de
color porque aquí los combatimos eso
para señalar que a lo largo de estos
años hemos combatido
y desmovilizar dos mil hombres entre el
l n las licencias de las farc y el
programa de sometimiento para el clan
del golfo y hemos logrado disminuir el
número de grupos armados organizados
como lo señalé pero aún tenemos un país
con violencia por el narcotráfico
quienes asesinan a los líderes sociales
son estos grupos armados ilegales en el
80% de los homicidios colectivos y
masacres se originaron y ciencias de la
farc o el eln el clan del golfo quienes
están asesinando a los reincorporados de
las farc son las mismas disidencias de
las farc
quienes han cometido los principales
actos terroristas ln por eso combatir
esos grupos es una forma de disminuir
esa violencia que ellos mismos generan
por eso a pesar de que hay estos actos
violentos son mucho menores que los que
se presentaban a 10 e 10 años no debido
a morir ningún líder social no veo
ningún reincorporado por supuesto que
esté cumpliendo con todas las normas a
morir pero son ellos que esos grupos
armados ilegales los que en sus disputas
en sus rentas criminales en su actuar en
su confrontación
desafortunadamente cometen este tipo de
hechos por eso los combatimos ha hecho y
por eso también buscamos protegen la
vida claro usted me habla de que parte
de esos grupos armados ilegales se han
trasladado a venezuela sin embargo los
reportes que hacen las organizaciones y
me gustaría también que me diera los
datos que maneja el ministerio de
defensa y el gobierno colombiano en
general las cifras son del territorio
colombiano por tanto se dice que hay un
50% más de violencia en el gobierno duke
de la que había en el final del mandato
de santos por tanto
que se está haciendo para proteger a los
excombatientes a los líderes sociales
desde la fuerza pública aunque sean los
grupos armados ilegales los que están
detrás de esas masacres que se está
haciendo desde el estado desde el
gobierno para proteger a esas personas
como mí en la violencia cual es el
indicador de violencia el indicador de
violencia es número de secuestros número
de misiles
para determinar y actos terroristas que
pueden estar sucediendo la violencia
como indicador general tiene que tener
un indicador concreto y objetivo el
presidente de edu que tuvo en el año
2019 la tasa de homicidios más baja de
los últimos 46 años y la tasa de
secuestro es más baja y los obtiene el
año 2019 los últimos 36 años esos los
hechos cuando tú tienes en un país un
país que protege la vida que tiene menos
asesinatos y menos homicidios significa
que la política de seguridad está
funcionando o que la política de pasco
legalidad también está funcionando por
supuesto nunca ha negado el gobierno que
hoy tenemos grupos arma alzados en armas
que se alimentan del narcotráfico que
buscan generar viales y por eso los
combatimos pero una es partir del hecho
que en colombia cuando cerró la coro no
había ninguna violencia aquí no había
paz completa aquella tres grupos armados
organizados y una tasa de homicidios que
estaba llegando a los 25 26 por cada
100.000 habitantes cuando un país se
protege la vida y tiene menos éstas ya
domicilio es que está funcionando la
política de seguridad y la política de
paz el número de asesinato de líderes
sociales comparado con el pasado es
mucho más bajo por supuesto no debería
existir ningún asesinato
a ninguno de los miembros de
reincorporados en este caso por ejemplo
el número de masa que se redujeron entre
el año pasado y este año y ver ninguno
porque es que ninguna sociedad puede
legitimar una masacre y mucho menos
cuando se presenta entre estos grupos
pero la tasa de homicidios que mide el
país hoy es más baja y a lo largo de
este 4 no tendrá la playa el promedio
más bajo entonces eso es una forma de
demostrar que la política de seguridad
más si funciona no estamos en un estado
perfecto no negamos que hay nivel de
violencia no negamos que grupos armados
ilegales y por eso los combatimos con
decisión y combatimos y buscamos
neutralizar sus fuentes de
financiamiento que es el narcotráfico
que es el que origina los asesinatos los
homicidios colectivos el desplazamiento
forzado me preguntaba el tema de las
cifras porque indepaz hablaba de 930
líderes asesinados por supuesto el
gobierno de edu que maneja las las
cifras de homicidios más bajas porque no
estamos en el contexto de la guerra que
ha habido en las últimas cinco décadas
como tal desde el fin del acuerdo en
2016 entonces le preguntaba por esas
cifras las proponer un ejemplo y es por
eso aquí lo primero es nada justifica
que un ser humano ni líder social ni
idea mental ahora o pierda la vida pero
si se de cifras comparativas
que presentar en colombia hoy hay
aproximadamente 5 millones de líderes
sociales que pertenecen a juntas de
acción comunal si tú coges la tasa de
esos 900 que fallecieron
desafortunadamente no estamos en nos
están es un tema complejo no existe
ninguno pero aquí se ha venido avanzando
en una política de seguridad que busca
proteger a los líderes sociales cuando
llegas a determinar quiénes fueron los
responsables son las disidencias de las
farc es el clan del golfo es el ln y por
eso es tan importante compartirlo si
querías son la fuente alimento por eso
mismo cuántas de las personas que están
detrás de esos asesinatos
y de esas masacres están judicial izadas
procesadas encarceladas perseguidas por
por ciento siempre de los cabecillas o
lln o del clan del golfo o de las
licencias de las farc están capturadas y
por supuesto un solo ejemplo botón y el
botón ya el máximo narcotraficante de 10
años buscado por la justicia finalmente
capturado y extraditado responsable y
así tiene más de 120 cargos ante la
justicia cargos que tienen que ver con
asesinato redes sociales desplazamientos
forzados asesinatos policías asesinato y
reincorporados mencionaba a usted a
otoniel después de su extradición el
clan del golfo extinto por según el
presidente iván duque
mostró su fuerza en un tercio más de un
tercio de los departamentos del país
creando zozobra a muchos ciudadanos y
desplegando su fuerza y su violencia
porque la respuesta del estado fue
tardía porque no se aplacó antes ese ese
paro armado decretado por el plan del
golfo después de la extradición
yo creo que primero el clan del golfo es
un grupo que se ha visto como principal
objetivo a lo largo de estos cuatro años
8.000 miembros de su estructura ya fuera
armada o
delincuencial han sido capturados más de
250 de sus cabecillas de las cabecillas
mayores o menores han sido capturados
por este gobierno y adicionalmente la
captura de otoniel lo que hace cierra un
ciclo porque se llama el clan del golf
en el año hace 12 años esta 10 años
están buscando a otoniel porque se llama
clan del golf porque era una familia era
otoniel el primo el abuelo es la hermana
el cuñado era un clan porque se llama
clan familiar así actúan como clan
porque desaparece como un clan hoy
después de las operaciones hechas por la
fuerza pública no existe esa familia o
han sido capturados judicial izados o
extraditados o neutralizado considera
que el mayor logro del gobierno de iván
duque es la extradición de alias otoniel
ese es uno de los principales victorias
pero por supuesto aunque han 3 reductos
del clan del golfo 3 de los cabecillas
que siguen nutriéndose al narcotráfico
que tienen negocios con el cártel de los
balcanes que tienen negocios con el
cártel de sinaloa carteles mexicanos y
siguen exportando el 60% de la coca que
produce el país por eso es necesario
seguir combatiéndolos y combatimos esos
reductos porque sabemos que originan
violencia el clan del golfo quería
evitar la extradición de obtener
posicionarse para llegar a la gp y
convertirse en un grupo político que el
próximo gobierno tuviera negociación y
para eso querían hacerse fuertes y
mostrarse fuertes pero al final fueron
capturados los que cometieron sus
delitos
a posicionarse políticamente para una
futura negociación o para un futuro
perdón social como por ahí están
promoviendo el gobierno de iván duque
dijo que salía a las calles a proteger a
la ciudadanía en el paro armado para
desbloquear vías y para que cesara ese
constreñimiento de la movilidad en más
de un tercio de los departamentos ese
objetivo de desbloquear vías también
también fue uno de los objetivos del
paro nacional para el actuar de la
fuerza pública sin embargo la
desproporción en la fuerza
por parte de policías soldados y fuerzas
de seguridad fue desproporcional según
algunas organizaciones internacionales
como la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos
la organización de las naciones unidas
etcétera porque ese cambio de criterio
de desbloquear vías en los dos contextos
pero con distinta proporción de la
violencia no realmente son dos
situaciones completamente diferentes una
lo que sucedió en el año 2018 el 2019 20
el año pasado el 2021 entre abril y
junio fue un efecto de vandalismos y
bloqueos sistemáticos y multitudinarios
utilizando poblaciones
pero aquí la fuerza pública actúa en
derecho y de acuerdo con la constitución
tuvimos entre el 28 de abril al 30 de
junio del año pasado 15.000
manifestaciones pacíficas muchas por
inconformidad social pero también hubo
en 1700 oportunidades en donde no fueron
pacíficas en donde los manifestantes
infiltrados por grupos armados ilegales
cometieron delitos en contra de la ley
una manifestación pacífica no es
destruir un palacio de justicia obstruir
una vía por días sin permitir que
llegaran alimentos a la población si
permite que llegaran con drogas a la
población es una vida y esa y estoy
seguro que hay que actuar esos grupos
generaron violencia no manifestaciones y
en eso tengo que actuar el estado y fue
una actuación violenta en contra de
civiles y en contra de la misma policía
2.700 policías heridos 2500 civiles
heridos en este proceso o sea que aquí
no hubo una afectación únicamente de la
posición de diferentes organizaciones
más de 80 víctimas civiles y más de
2.000 actos de violencia contra los
manifestantes de ninguna manera hubo 80
afectaciones de civiles las afectaciones
de la fiscalía son que reporta por
ejemplo la ong claro pero aquí el único
que puede decir quién es se murió no es
la fiscalía general de la nación la
fiscalía general de la acción está se
está identificando 26 casos y sobre 26
casos no ha juzgado si hubo una
responsabilidad o no una la información
que pueda dar una ong pero hay un sector
de la justicia que tiene legitimidad
determinar quién fue y por qué sucedió
el hecho allí dijeron que había 500
desaparecidos y ninguno ninguna de los
desaparecidos en la policía actuó en
defensa de los colombianos en defensa de
la constitución y la ley y allí donde
hubo hechos que fueron más allá y hubo
algún tipo de abuso por la policía
inmediatamente se abrieron
investigaciones 170 investigaciones se
abrieron o que están en manos de la
fiscalía o en manos de la procuraduría
porque en colombia tengo cero tolerancia
con cualquier comportamiento que tenga
un policía en contra de los derechos
humanos en contra de la misma ley o el
régimen disciplinario que ellos tienen
señor ministro nos quedamos casi sin
tiempo vamos a hacerle una pregunta muy
muy rápida hago un consejo que le dé a
su sucesor no sabemos quién será pero
algún consejo para el futuro ministro de
defensa muy breve yo creería que para
colombia y es fundamental para el
próximo ministro de defensa- seguir una
ruta muy importante y es saber que si no
se combate el narcotráfico no se elimine
la violencia en colombia y en esa medida
hay que fortalecer las capacidades de la
fuerza pública perfecto muchísimas
gracias diego molano ministro de defensa
de colombia por su tiempo aquí y marta
muchas gracias a todos ustedes a ustedes
muchas gracias pueden conseguir más
información en france 24 y france 24